when Homeland Security began asking
hotel staff to report heavy condom use
by their customers it came as a surprise
to just about everyone who was paying
attention but this has been part of an
ongoing anti-sex trafficking initiative
including mall ads employee training
modules and public service announcements
soliciting for the purpose of
prostitution recruiting underage girls
for the purpose of prostitution what's
going on here as recent blogger
elizabeth nolan brown points out law
enforcement agencies have been steadily
focusing on sex work as the result of an
unlikely coalition since the 90s like a
kind of group of radical feminists and a
group of christian fundamentalists have
been really working to get all
prostitution redefined a sex trafficking
it's been a sort of long game strategy
that's been ramping up throughout the
whole oughts
and then in the past few years though
has really taken off because there's no
distinction between consensual and
forced sex work government efforts to
stop sex trafficking ends up invading
personal privacy talk about why homeland
security is interested in your condom
use homeland security has been having a
lot of initiatives to try and train
various industries on what they consider
the signs of sex trafficking and so this
includes airline staff and strip club
workers and also a big push is for hotel
staff and so they've been putting out
all these training modules and campaign
posters and things to hotel maids and
clerks with signs of sex trafficking and
this includes things like garbage cans
containing many used cars yes they said
one of them was too many used condoms
things like ask me to have the mini bar
restocked too frequently I'm having too
few possessions or too many possessions
it's just a lot of really silly things
when you get to the end of the you know
all of the things taken together it's
pretty much any activity could be
construed as suspicious you've also
written a lot about feds taking their
websites talk about some of the websites
that have been taken down and the
rationale for that they recently helped
in Seattle take down a site called the
review board Department of Homeland
Security over the summer took down
rentboy calm which was a gay escort site
and they've been going after
backpage.com which is a classified
advertising site much like Craigslist
but they haven't been able to actually
make a significant dent in that yet but
basically their rationale is that
these are sites where anybody can post
an ad I mean there's thousands if not
hundreds of thousands of ads going up
every day from users you know selling
cars asking for babysitting services and
there's also a section that has adult
services including some legal and some
illegal forms of sex work and
occasionally people who are sex
trafficking victims their pimps or their
traffickers will post ads there and so
the federal government has been trying
to hold Backpage criminally liable for
the ads that are posted there and some
of these other sites hold them
criminally liable for the user-generated
content that is posted and that
contravenes established precedent or
legal precedent where the publisher of a
site is not necessarily responsible for
the material right it goes against like
about 20 years of yeah of policy in that
area and Backpage is actually suing the
federal government right now to try and
get that liability removed talk a little
bit about what kind of things get
covered under you know whenever Super
Bowls happen and we're trying to crack
down on sex trafficking yeah because of
the whole myth that there's a lot of sex
trafficking on the Super Bowl we do a
lot of stings and basically it's cops
posing as sex workers online and then
having men who want to solicit
prostitution come and meet them at a
hotel and then arresting them when
they're there does law enforcement
whether at the national level or the
state or local level talk about how they
slide back and forth between kind of
honest prostitution for lack of a better
term and sex trafficking and and why is
one considered so much worse than the
other yeah I mean sex trafficking is
when someone is being forced into it
that's the thing that should be a crime
not consensual sex between adults and
they just sort of almost use the two
words interchangeably I mean you saw all
these press releases about this national
dawn sting day and they were all saying
you know this was aimed at sex
trafficking or even this was aimed at
child sex trafficking but ultimately
they arrested I think over 550 men for
solicitation of undercover cops they
arrested at least a hundred women for
prostitution and they found seven
teenagers that were working in
prostitution so and though they're
legally defined as sex trafficking
victims so ultimately when you've been
even if they're even if they're not
forces so we don't know if they are
being forced or not one of the people
that was arrested was because a 20 year
old got arrested because she was working
with a 17 year old and that's legally
made her a sex trafficker so that's one
of them that was the rest
so you see that even though it's being
billed as a sex trafficking initiative
to stop it
it just ends up sort of like a giant
massive national vise thing what is
driving the interest in sex traffic or
kind of what seems to be a heightened
awareness among law enforcement in the
media about sex trafficking is there an
actual increase in sex trafficking or
you know why why are we suddenly talking
about sex trafficking as opposed to
prostitution since the 90s like a kind
of group of radical feminists and a
group of Christian fundamentalists have
been really working to get all
prostitution redefined a sex trafficking
it's been a sort of long game strategy
that's been ramping up throughout the
whole Ott's and then really in the past
few years though has really taken off
for a couple of reasons more media
attention more congressional attention
some new laws that got a lot more money
going to states to work on this issue so
they have a whole lot of money that they
can use if they just call Vice things
sex trafficking stings so I think it's a
lot of different things but it's that
nowhere in those does it seem like an
actual increase in the sex trafficking
is to blame for this increased division
well we'll leave it there Elizabeth
thanks for talking to us yeah for Reason
TV I'm Nick Gillespie
[Music]